22 diese bewegung hat den dating markt
revolutioniert und unsere gesellschaft
verändert was macht das mit unseren
beziehungen und dem kennenlernen von
neuen menschen und welche rolle spielen
technik und dating es dabei darum geht
es in diesem video
in der römischen mythologie gab es den
gott der liebe aber oder auch coppito
genannt und cupido hat den pfeil der
liebe auf die menschen abgeschossen und
in ihnen ein gefühl geweckt und
heutzutage ist dieser fall nichts
anderes als ein algorithmus der liebe in
uns auslöst und das kann auch beim
online dating passieren wenn wir nach
rechts oder links zweiten dass wir
vielleicht mister oder miss right
begegnen eine ganze generation hat ihr
dating leben ins internet verlagert was
sie da suchen die einen die große liebe
und eine beziehung die anderen schnellen
sex freundschaften oder ego booster das
netz bietet raum für unterschiedlichste
bedürfnisse und online dating liegt im
trend jede und jeder dritte der 30 bis
49 jährigen in deutschland hat dating
plattformen schon einmal genutzt ist
auch eine schönere story im supermarkt
nach dem gleichen apfel zugreifen ich
bezweifle nur oder vage anzuzweifeln wie
oft das dann wirklich passiert ich finde
aber auch nicht schlimm zu sagen später
hey ich habe meinen mann über eine
dating
nutzt seit über zehn jahren die
unterschiedlichsten online dating
plattformen für sie ist das kennenlernen
über einen app längst nicht mehr scham
behaftet ganz im gegenteil für sie
erschließen sich dadurch ganz neue orte
deswegen dated sie auch gerade in paris
sie kann mobil arbeiten und hofft auf
ihr liebesglück in der stadt der liebe
ich glaube die meisten leute würden eher
naiv sagen aber ich bin hier in paris
eben auch um
eventuell
partner zu finden hier die liebe zu
finden in der stadt die ich liebe das
wäre so larry page es wird halt
schwieriger im laufe der zeit zum
beispiel im freundeskreis fündig zu
werden weil ein freundeskreis es auch
irgendwann gesättigt dann denke ich mir
es ist gut auch bei außerhalb seiner
babbel zu schauen und deswegen das macht
online dating auch so interessant für
mich ich lernen leute kennen die ich
vielleicht sonst nicht kennenlernen
würde und dann ist es im online dating
kosmos natürlich schön zu sehen dass es
recht viel auswahl gibt und dass man
sich nicht mit
dem abfinden muss was man gerade hat
sondern auch sagen kann hey das tut mir
nicht gut und ich weiß auch wenn es
jetzt gerade schwer ist aber da wird
schon jemand anderes kommt
der einfach besser passt aber wer oder
was entscheidet denn wer besser passt
oder wer generell zu uns passt im online
dating sind algorithmen die heimlichen
matchmaker die suche nach der liebe wird
zur programmieraufgaben zahlenkolonnen
stadt schmetterlinge im bauch die daten
dafür stellen die nutzer innen selbst
zur verfügung wer einem am ende aus dem
riesigen pool an möglichkeiten angezeigt
wird ist also kein zufall sondern
mathematik ein algorithmus ist am ende
nichts anderes als ein kleines monster
das futter benötigt und dieses futter
sind eben die information die ich an
gebe nina seite ist gründerin von
inclusive tech data analyzer und
beschäftigt sich mit big data und
künstlicher intelligenz sie weiß welche
gefahren und chancen hinter den
algorithmen der dating apps stecke wenn
ich mich auf einer dating- ab
registrieren dann bin ich ab dem moment
ein user und ich muss innerhalb der
suchmaske information angeben und
basierend auf den ganzen informationen
können dann dating app anbieter anhand
dieser gesammelten daten erkenntnisse
daraus gewinnen was meine vorlieben und
präferenzen sein könnten bei der suche
nach dem passenden mensch führen geheime
algorithmen zum nächsten date dabei
wurde häufig auch in attraktivitäts wert
eingesetzt der disco das prinzip
menschen mit hoher beliebtheit haben
auch große chancen auf das liebes wenn
ich zum beispiel gezeigt werde von
jemandem der eine so genannte 10 ist
dann bin ich rapide beliebt auf kinder
als wenn ich ein match erhalte von einer
person die mit einer sogenannten 3
bewertet wird beziehungsweise als
weniger beliebt oder attraktiv geld und
genau so funktioniert dieser rosskur
weswegen er auch immens unter kritik
steht bei beliebtheit wiederum seinen
ursprung hat auf die definition von norm
schöner attraktivität heute verwendet
unter anderem kinder den elogen nicht
mehr schreibt das unternehmen
stattdessen soll jetzt unsere online
aktivität in den apps der garant für ein
passendes match sein raffiniert denn das
ziel der unternehmen ist ja nicht dass
wir uns schon nach einem swype verlieben
sondern dass wir möglichst lange online
bleiben aber wird diese auswahl nicht
auch im normalen leben getroffen frage
ich mich dann wahrscheinlich okay ich
bestimme mehr meinen eigenen algorithmus
in dem ich eine bar wähle in die ich
gehe aber warum besuche ich diese bar
weil auf instagram wie man schöne fotos
davon gemacht hat weil eine freundin mir
davon erzählt hat war ich in einem
magazin gesehen habe habe ich dann einen
eigenen algorithmus kreiert sozusagen
und es ist so ein bisschen gruselig
darüber nachzudenken klar wenn es um
diese app geht und haye die bestimmen
wer mir angezeigt wird aber es ist sind
hier auch so viele menschen dass ich
nicht irgendwie angst darüber habt das
dass das jemand bestimmt hat wenig
kennenlernen sondern ich habe ja immer
noch die wahl und die wahl zwischen echt
vielen vielen menschen die auf dating
apps unterwegs sind und nicht nur
zwischen 3 oder so wenn wir die
kontrolle über unser liebesleben
einen computer abgeben hat es nicht nur
auswirkungen auf unser persönliches
schicksal durch die algorithmen
verstärkt sich noch ein ganz anderes
phänomen da das matchmaking eben von
einem algorithmus determiniert wird der
darüber entscheidet mit wem ich
zusammenkomme und selbst bei algorithmen
kann es dann auch dazu kommen dass eine
gewisse homogenität herrscht dadurch
dass ich meine soziale klasse ebene und
andere informationen preisgeben wenn ich
die dating republik judith verbände kann
ich zum beispiel nicht nur nach dem
geschlecht filtern sondern auch nach der
ebene stehe ich zb auf menschen die
asiatische stämmig sind schwarz sind
oder kaukasische all diese information
kann ich dort angeben und eine studie
von der cornell university aus dem jahr
2018 hat aufgezeigt dass dieser filter
bei oki cupid als auch anderen plattform
dazu führt dass ich viel mehr
voreingenommenheiten beim dating habe
weil ich vielleicht
voreingenommenheiten habt gegenüber
bestimmten kulturen und ethnien und die
wahrscheinlichkeit sogar dadurch
geringer ist dass ich am ende eine
interkulturelle oder in technische
partnerschaft habe in dating apps sollen
asiatische männer und schwarze frauen
weniger oft anfragen bekommen warnen
auch verbraucher stellen das senke ihren
attraktiven tesco und führe dazu dass
sie seltener als match für andere
vorgeschlagen würden auf diese weise
trage der algorithmus dazu bei dass sich
gesellschaftliche vorurteile weiter
festigen trotzdem ist und kann online
dating für viele auch eine chance und
einzig space sein zum beispiel für alex
er dated männer und berichtet über seine
dating erfahrungen in der lgbt community
gay meine freunde auch da ist es total
normal einfach wir sind und wenn wir die
romeo aufgewachsen das war die erste
dating plattform im netz und ich bin
selber aus berlin aber freunde von mir
kommt vielleicht schon kleinen dorf
irgendwo und dann das die einzige
möglichkeit gewesen gleichgesinnte zu
treffen deswegen würde ich sagen für die
lgbt cube szene ist das völlig normal
sich online studenten ich weiß aber von
meinen freunden dass für diese gar nicht
normal ist also gerade in der lgbt
community ist das glaube ich wichtig
dass es diese räume gibt was ihr einfach
spaces sind wenn ich irgendwie aus dem
dorf lebe in sachsen jetzt bis ins
klischee pony aber unter einfach
vielleicht nicht so viele andere games
sind und wenn man in einem hinten klappt
und wie ein anstrich gibt es dann aufs
maul wie man das vielleicht auch nicht
riskieren also insofern ist es glaube
ich wichtig dass das räumen gibt wo
leute egal wie sie lieben und wen sie
lieben eben auch diese räume haben ihre
kate kennen zu lernen und das betrifft
ja nicht nur djs das betrifft ja auch
trans menschen und ganz viele andere die
und wenn dies vielleicht auch
schwieriger es war das auch keine
etablissements gibt geschützte räume für
bestimmte gruppen
das wirkt sich auf das zusammenleben der
ganzen gesellschaft aus meint der
soziologe krüge
so ein safe space ich meine das spiel in
der homosexuellen community an natürlich
diese online dating apps sehr sehr viel
verändert sich sehr verschoben ins
internet und das ist wichtig das ist
solche orte geht wo man eben auch frei
von von gesellschaftlicher
diskriminierung von anna leuten die
einem irgendwie bedrohungen oder
angreifen oder auch nur kritisieren dass
man sich dort treffen kann online decken
damit verdienen konzerne viel geld und
sie bieten immer neue features treffen
wir uns in zukunft nur noch virtuell und
wie profitieren dating unternehmen von
unserer suche nach der liebe darüber
haben wir unter anderem mit kai dröge
der sozialpsychologin dr johanna degen
dem zukunftsforscher tristan hawks und
dating app nutzer innen gesprochen in
der dritten folge der neuen doku reihe
titel empire dreht sich also alles um
liebe macht und geld und natürlich wie
die zukunft aussieht
stichwort metapher
ob wir also in zukunft in der zu allen
räumen avatare dayton das erfahrt ihr in
der doku liebe macht und meta was das
dating imperium den link dafür findet
ihr hier